I for one am going to demand the return
of Topher Grace so a little more
information about Sony supposed venom
movie has come out now nothing that I'm
going to talk about it so far as I'm
aware at least has been made official
like coming from Sony but it has been
reported I believe the story originated
with Collider which usually have a
pretty decent track record as far as
these things tend to go now there's two
major things one of which was something
that we kind of knew already and it's
just a confirmation the other of which
is sort of new information the
confirmation is yes the venom movie will
not connect to spider-man homecoming or
the MCU like at all so this is going to
be completely standalone although that
does not necessarily mean it's not going
to have its own weird connections to
other things like if Sony makes other
standalone spider-man spin-off movies
that don't actually involve Tom Hollands
spider-man those could be connected to
venom like if they did the sinister six
movie but didn't use Michael Keaton's
vulture and didn't use anything that any
of the whatever theoretically just
whatever um there was the bigger thing
is is that the indication and the plan
does appear to be a hard r-rated horror
type movie for venom and I have very
mixed feelings about that now on the one
hand I have to admit this this might be
the one thing that they could do that
would make any kind of sense in terms of
telling a venom story as a standalone
not connected to spider-man and you
could do it with any of the various
origins whether he is whether the
symbiote in from space whether it's
created in a lab you can do that with a
horror edge and if you're going for that
for that feel and that vibe where it's
you know it's really something
terrifying and creepy you don't
necessarily need spider-man to sell that
so if they are determined to have it
disconnected this is probably the best
way to go
that being said even though this allows
for a more standalone story if you're
not connecting it in some way just
later man what is there to distinguish
this from any generic alien horror movie
what is there to distinguish this from
alien what is there to distinguish this
from species what is there to this thing
was this from life Sony's own you know
sci-fi horror movie that some folks even
floated might have been a secret venom
origin movie it wasn't so while on the
one hand going the hard our rating makes
a certain amount of sense in terms of
decoupling it from spider-man on the
other hand you know it's a genre that
how are they how are they going to stand
out in that genre and I suppose the
question is whether venom and the
symbiote is going to be an antihero or
just be a monster
staying hard our horror leans more
towards the monster or at the very least
if the going antihero then whoever it
bonds to whether they decide to do Eddie
Brock or Flash Thompson or any of the
number of the other people that the
symbiote has been bonded to at any point
and they have that character try and use
it for good but it's corrupting them and
that's the horror angle and like just
you know usually is going to be the main
the main horror thing so if they kind of
go into here that way and it's the
internal struggle like maybe but the
whole thing just feels it feels very
trendy it feels very bandwagon jumping
it feels like the real cynic in me feels
like Sony announced that we're going to
do a venom movie and then there was a
sizable fan reaction some of which I saw
in the comments on my own channel going
boy
I hope they do a hard-r horror type and
Sony went oh that's how they wanted to
do it we'll do that now I'm not claiming
that's what actually happened this may
have been the plan from the beginning
but that's that's the feel that I'm
getting in even if they have planted
ahead time you know they're just they're
only going this direction because you
know Deadpool proved that it could work
and Logan proved that that wasn't a
fluke but even those things is like a
horror superhero things I mean this is
New Age it's uncharted territory but
does them actually demand on our rating
again like like I said the last time I
did a video on this I haven't been
keeping up with venom so I don't know
how harsh the character may have gotten
I know he can't potentially be
intimidating and scary but he's always
just been a very sort of pg-13 kind of
monster yeah he roughs people up yeah he
kills people on occasion but nothing
about him
'only sins and my understanding of the
character inherently lends itself to a
hard are that proper saying that you
couldn't do one I'm just not sure that
it is as natural progression as it is
with something like Deadpool or what
they ended up doing with Logan because I
mean even though Wolverine a little bit
like venom in that way like has harsher
elements but has always been a little
bit more family-friendly so stretch but
you know general audience friendly in
the movies we always knew he was being
nerfed in terms of like the guys got the
claws and he can't properly rip into
people cuz pg-13 so there was always
that so you know you could still kind of
lend us up to an R rating in that way
bubble down I mean I know he hit his
heyday in the 90s and you know the 90s
were all about true but it was always
kind of a safe homogenized extreme that
they that they did it like it looks cool
and edgy but really at the end of day it
wasn't much again if the character is
gone more in a legitimate horrid
direction in more recent years I be open
to hearing about that and looking over
this you know sort of the wiki's the
table system sample issues that stuff is
like yeah he's gone dark in the same way
a lot of characters have gone dark and
recent decade or so but nothing that the
least of my eye demands and our ratings
so the whole thing just feels very
bandwagon jumping but the other thing to
keep in mind with the with Deadpool and
Logan is they were relatively low budget
certainly compared to most other
superhero movies then if you're going to
realize them especially if you're doing
the symbiote like add the goop and you
really want to get horror you want to
get monstrous with it it might require a
bit more money and I'm afraid what Sony
might do is try and go on our rating
chasing a trend and then on top of that
throw a ton of money at it and that
those two don't mix if you're going to
go on our rated comic book superhero
property that's fine but you need to be
constrained you need to be very targeted
and precise about what you're doing if
you're doing the more scattershot
you know just throw everything out the
wall and throw a ton of money at it
these are keys probably their best I
mean overall I'm just left with the
question why is this even a thing that's
happening and of course I know the
actual reason why this is the thing
that's happening this is the thing
that's happening is because Sony
desperately wants more franchise
tentpoles
because they're having they're having
trouble I mean the movie I already
mentioned life came and nobody really
cared it just seems like the company is
struggling in its film division lately
and you know superheroes are hot they
have access to these properties and
they're just like what what can we do
we're not going to we're not going to
wait we're not going to force the
connection with the MCU where we have to
deal with Marvel and their approval what
can we do with what we've got and venom
is something where you can do something
so they're doing it even though I still
don't think it's a good idea but I mean
that that said r-rated [ __ ] angle it at
least has the potential to be something
new in the superhero landscape as exists
because really if someone's going to go
r-rated horror sized DC should be the
ones getting on this we should we should
why don't we have a Swamp Thing movie
yet come on I mean they've got that
discuss a man may be a Spectre if
somebody was going to get on an r-rated
horrid hinged superhero you want to
thought it would have been DC they're
dragging their feet Sony's you got to
try and fill the void maybe in a word
I'm still just I'm really skeptical
because the fact that it is disconnected
from spider-man just kind of in my mind
shows the hollowness of the enterprise
and how it's just there's no artistic
merit behind or at least no artistic
intent behind it the intent is all the
money and I mean stoon here they're
trying to make money I know that but
usually the best product comes when they
in somebody somewhere along the line
whether it's a producer directors but
somebody has an artistic vision that
they know they can extract money from
you get the worst of when it's like
somebody goes we can make money off that
somebody find an artsy guy make money
off that and that's more what venom is
feeling like at this point the process
but you know we'll keep an eye out we'll
see what happens they're saying they're
going to start shooting in the fall and
I'm going to come back to what I said
what I talked about it the first time
that's a really quick turnaround time if
they're latching onto that October of
next
your release date especially given again
venom it kind of CGI reliant it's that's
a tight schedule but and we'll see what
happens so far as I know alex kurtzman
still directing they've got a guy on the
script I'll keep an eye on it we'll see
what happens what are your thoughts on
ax is the news that venom that might be
a hard r-rated [ __ ] give you more hope
for the project let's hope for the
project do you still care did you ever
in any case whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council geeks give a listen to the
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]